the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
I hope you're getting excited about the
trip so there are a few things that I
managed to skip over last time one is
solar cookers somehow got dropped from
my presentation and they're kind of key
part of cooking that I want to talk
about but at least most of you guys have
investigated a little bit on your own
and then we also just talking about the
energy to boil water so in terms of
solar cookers there as a group of
Phoenix mentioned there are three types
so there's the concentrator or parabolic
method where you have some sort of
parabolic collector that's aiming the
heat onto your cooking cook stove which
is then heating up the material you have
the box method which is using a
greenhouse method where you have a
reflective device reflecting into the
greenhouse and that's pretty much the
design that Drupal Phoenix uses I
wouldn't call it a hybrid because the
hybrid has both that greenhouse but also
uses some parabolic features to collect
the energy and you can see that the
costs you can imagine the cost of these
three devices shown varies and so you
can get very inexpensive versions of all
of these that the parabolic is
definitely the hardest to get super
cheap and very expensive versions so I
wanted to start by just talking about
what you think might be some pros and
cons of solar cookers
question yeah
what
just sheet metal
so a cheap metal is pretty yeah it's
hard to get a really good reflection off
of it so i think i've seen some that are
like basically mirrors so I think what
that is this is like a plastic that's
super shiny that's just laminated onto
the cardboard so a whole range from
expensive to non no so this is an open
pan so this is concentrating it on the
pan so that these this is the difference
the concentrators is just you know
shining a strong ray of heat on to
something slow cookers are it's very
rarely electrical I've never seen
cook but then I would have definitely
think about line to the panel outside on
the roof collecting collecting the race
collecting dust like solar energy make
transferring it into like electrical
energy and getting it to
to sort of hooker in this so I think
that would be a really good estimation
exercise to figure out what it takes to
make a solar cooker that's an electrical
solar cooker because do you remember how
many watts the typical stove or oven is
yeah and so like a typical like burner
is a thousand to 1500 watts the typical
oven is 3000 watts so we're talking
really different scopes in terms of what
a cell phone charger is and what cooking
is it needs to be and so that's a high
barrier to entry so you need to look
into the viability of that okay so can
we make a list of what you think are the
bonuses of sore cookers and what are
some of the drawbacks Benji yeah so it's
free energy yeah
condens that you might not be able to
have right outside your home like that
girl standing in a river it's probably
not outside um so uh how do we so it
needs to be like it needs to be out
stuff kinda yeah
Center as they can right yeah so you're
you're you're cooking options are
limited
so yeah you can absolutely fry food with
the concentrator but it can be hard to
get a low heat if you want a low heat in
a concentrator Carter excuse me
portability yeah so I'll put that in the
middle well and there's a real
well but you can see here so like this
is a highly portable solar cooker that
that parabolic country to actually folds
up into something that's not much bigger
like it's significantly smaller than
this so that is super portable whereas
the content that concentrator is a fixed
location so summer portable some are not
and then if they're portable that can be
helpful but then limited by size so I
think actually leaving in the middle is
reasonable yeah I don't know if that is
true any more true than it is for any
stove any other thoughts
yeah I see
yeah so no emissions which yields better
health no no no fuel collection which
sort of links to that one so because
it's a good time or money generally
Oh
ok yeah Angie
the office
so yeah so because people do use their
fires for heating for mosquito control
for light sometimes yeah okay super so I
think that's a pretty good list to give
you some background solar cookers were
invented in the mid-1700s so they've
been around for a really long time and I
think that is an indicator of how this
is a great technology in some cases but
isn't ever going to be the killer app
that solves the world's cooking
challenges because we want to thank if
they've been around since the 1700s that
the refinement that takes it to killer
app would have been developed already
but the cons of it weather-dependent is
time dependent you need to be in a sunny
location you need to be outside are all
really huge so some of the challenges
with the concentrators are the glare and
just how hot it is so it's kind of hard
to see because the quality of the
picture has gone down going through the
projector but this woman is sort of
grimacing because it's so bright that
it's actually hard to to deal with and
it's also very hot where it is yeah yeah
so the concentrators in particular are
dangerous and so people are really
concerned especially with kids you know
it's getting not permanently but
temporary blinded or burnt there's also
issues that you can imagine how easy
that would be well uh it's not a really
quick question for all
please can you please stand up and the
recipe just look around get a good look
at who who has laces in who doesn't this
one clipped on here okay thank you guys
you can sit down so I hate to break it
to you like this but you know I can see
a lot of the way you tied your laces and
a lot of you just use like the simple
like bunny ear is kind of not you learn
when you're like five or six you know
which is great when you learned it and
work well but honestly now it's kind of
a dumb not to use I know you've been
using your whole life but you know I can
stand up here and tell you that because
so I'm a graduate student here
mechanical engineering which if you
haven't heard is probably the best
mechanical engineering department in the
world so you know I've learned all about
design and like good designs and bad
designs and these bunny ear knots are
pretty bad designs you know if you want
we could sit here and analyze the
stresses in them and kind of where our
the equilibrium points and why is it
stays hide and why does it always come
untied but you know the summary of all
that is just it's a bad not and you guys
should learn a new one but thankfully
I'm here and I'm going to go through and
teach you how to type it or not okay so
I'm going to kind of step out of that
character and ask you just real quickly
to share kind of thoughts or feelings of
that experience and kind of what I said
or what I did that made you think or
feel the way you are now
okay that works other anyone else you
pointed out people who are doing it
wrong with a tender status yeah right
again I'll do everything well um see it
so any other thoughts about how i came
across i obviously have this idea that i
want to get you to learn how to tie your
shoes differently do you think that was
the best approach so it was good you're
really confident and so it was easy to
listen to you and your kind of argument
at the flow here in conversation was
really easy flooded way
also new your over country present just
simple topic and if I does he write the
way mighty thing I think for us it's
good because role that means here for
sway I don't know how to go with other
people like see you think you know
extremely huge you thought you were
better than us like arrogant exactly
yeah that was trying to be yeah right i
mean i also i assumed there's a problem
right i assume that you're not happy
with the way you're tying your shoes
right and so this is how the better way
I mean like you said I ostracized
someone who tied their shoes differently
I didn't introduce myself at all I just
kind of barged in here and said hey let
me tell you about this right just the
personal connection is a pretty
important thing when you're working with
people you know also I didn't really ask
any information from you other than
could you stand up if you have shoes to
tie with laces right there is no other
exchange of information alright and so
if I'm coming in here and I'm trying to
help you with what I assume is a problem
it you know it's good to interact and
get some kind of information from you
guys and also I kind of imposed my value
of keeping shoes tied for a long time
over what might be a value of e to tie
your shoe or easy to untie your shoe or
just familiarity or the way the knot
looks you like the way it looks so
you're going to tie the bunny ears over
some other or not alright so I kind of
just assumed all these things and just
put them on you and said hey here's a
better way of doing it so I wanted to
use it as a simple illustration of some
circumstances you might find yourself in
going to Nicaragua soon when you're
working with people there on the
projects that youth you've been working
on so far where you're going into an
entirely different culture right working
in communities where you really don't
know how everything works and it'd be
really easy to come across in these same
kinds of ways so I wanted to just take a
minute if we can to divide up into the
teams all right you guys have been
working in teams and just talk about how
you might approach a situation where you
show up to a community
community partner and you know you have
the project you've been working on all
term and yes how would you go about
approaching the situation where you just
show up you get out of the van or you
get off the back of the truck and all
right you show up what do you do how do
you approach the the leaders that you
interact with or just the the people
there and so I I remember last year we
had about four teams or so okay so three
teams that actually works perfectly and
right before we do this I'll introduce
myself a little more I'm Steve fray I
know some some of you I'm a PhD student
kanika engineering here and helped out
with the 11 ergy last year but in order
to graduate I need to spend a little
more time on my dissertation this year
so I couldn't help out more than this
but yeah that's it i went to the
syndicate over last year and it was a
great time so you guys should be pumped
you leave like friday or saturday sunday
okay cool wait so let's just break up
and then we can quickly talk about it
and the three of us will kind of just
help facilitate and hope you guys think
about how you could kind of approach
this in a positive way
should we tie your shoes kindergarten
ish and those people have been in the
kitchen since before they could walk and
cooking you know
seven or eight years old so coming in
and saying you're putting on which is
somewhat some of us are saying you know
hopefully not though easy but
fundamentally suggesting changes is
comparable that you know sounds better
breasts and what are you talking about
and sometimes if there's like a
something that's relatively new you
might not even be aware of the problems
with it because you've just been doing
the same way the whole time so if you
observe something MA and you ask them if
you have any problems with their
something to improve miss ya not really
like it works pretty well and if you see
things that are that you think could be
improved you could ask them well know
what do you think about decreasing the
time for this to work by making this
change or something like that where it
might not be totally parent but you can
still ask how they would do it but
starting with what they see is
so trotting
sending carefully there
respecting what they've accomplished
while providing
ideas
Thanks so I know that was kind of Cesare
and weird but there's some of the
communities kind of walking in while
they're going about their daily lives
and getting completely interrupted so
that you could talk to them and so just
thinking about how awkward and weird
that felt and therefore what you can do
that wasn't like what Steve did because
he was definitely giving worst-case
scenario in order to minimize that
awkwardness and weirdness so back to
solar cookers ah so yeah so we're
talking about the concentrator it can be
so hot as to be dangerous especially for
kids but really for everyone you can see
that is a big wind catcher so they can
blow over pretty easily that's actually
an issue with the group of Phoenix
silica curse too because this panel is
so big that it catches in the wind and
then you it's there's also a risk of
when you're stirring spilling food onto
the reflector and then damaging the
reflector and how well it works so
there's some real drawbacks from the
parabolic from the greenhouse it's a
lower temperature and so you can really
only cook certain things but there's no
burning happening and you really don't
need to pay much attention to it apart
from adjusting the Sun the angle to the
Sun and then the combo has some of the
pros and some of the cons of the others
so we talked about the benefits are
pretty oh and the other thing here is
like you really can't stir this right
because as soon as you open it up you're
losing all your your heat and you have
to start all over again so it's a
challenging device so boxes are made out
of almost anything like I've seen
plastic I've seen would i've seen metal
so yeah so some of the challenges that
people can be frustrated about in
addition so one is that you have to cook
outdoors and so in cultures where
cooking indoors is standard cooking
outdoors pop poses a lot of challenges
so one is just the need for privacy
another is just risks of theft
of either your food under here cooker
and it's also for people who are used to
cooking around a fire it's a little less
social it can be and so that can be a
flipside of frustration the super
affordable ones like this one is made
out of cardboard and so they don't last
very long because termites tend to eat
them or other insects but they're very
inexpensive and then they use a plastic
bag just as your cover for your
greenhouse and again very inexpensive
but pretty short life and so then you
have with all these things breaking down
you have a supply chain issue of you
need to make sure that people are able
to get replacements and able to afford
replacements the size often times I sort
of gave you a hard time Carter about the
size thing but it's true that actually a
lot of the times they're relatively
small for how much they can cook and so
you can't always cook for all of your
family members so that's frustrating
there was an interesting sort of case
study where solar cookers were brought
to Kakuma which is a Kenyan refugee camp
for refugees from the Sudan and the
solar cookers international gave away a
bunch of cookers and there was actually
this cooker right here and so the people
are getting their solar cookers for free
and cooking was a huge issue in these
refugee camps because women were having
to leave the camp in order to get
firewood and when they were they were
regularly raped and so they needed an
alternative pretty severe severely
because there was no safe option for
cooking and they also were spending over
fifty percent of their income on
firewood if they were buying it so
really outrageous and in the end what
they found is that less than twenty
percent of people ended up using the
solar cookers more than one or two days
per week so that's a pretty low rate of
usage for something when you're facing
really severe costs either to your
bodily well-being or your income that
severe so I think that speaks to the
challenges of solar cooker adoption that
people don't love to use them
was that just because they were not used
to it or were there any major kind of
design flaws that made
well so people really don't like them
like these cookers work but all of these
rely issues like you can only cook
during what for lunch basically you
can't cook for breakfast you can't cook
for dinner you can only cook certain
types of foods etc etc make them a
really limit of limited value so on the
flipside at Kakuma is that there were a
bunch of single men there who were
separated from their families so
normally in the Sudan I am talking about
it yeah in the Sudan if you're a single
guy your mom cooks for you and it's not
normal for men to cook at all so either
your wife or your mom is cooking for you
and so these single men were separated
from their mom so they didn't have
anyone to cook with and it was really
socially inappropriate for them to cook
with wood and so they were actually the
adopters who use the solar cookers
because it was appropriate for them to
use these because they're really not
considered stoves the way a firewood
stove would be considered a stove so
that was the success story was that when
you needed a radically different option
it was it was relatively well adopted so
yeah so and the other aspect is that the
in this camp there was a food scarcity
also which is unsurprising and so asking
people to experiment with how they cook
when they don't know if they have enough
food is a huge request of people and so
I think that's part of the reason for
the lack of adoption was that I'm not
willing to try this wacky stove because
what if I ruin my food that means I
don't eat today and I don't know when
I'll be eating very much so that was the
the summary summary of solar cookers
there any questions on solar cookers I'm
sorry I dropped that over the charcoal
lecture that their stove lecture that
would have been the time to do it I
don't know how it got lost okay so now
we're finally going to talk about the
trip a bit sort of reverting back to
what Steve was talking about this is
lectures a little bouncing around
intentionally so that Steve could
interrupt us so the trip goals are
number one to have some Welland
identified well understood and well
documented projects ideally highly
relevant to deal of energy however if
you find some that are not at all energy
projects but are seem like interesting
projects we can often take these
projects and feed them into D lab design
or other d lab classes so if you learn
about some others feel free to document
them it's really helpful to D lab as a
community to have those extra projects
and then we've talked about a few
projects for you guys there may be
others that come up that are either
ideal for you to work on this semester
and that's fine to change course like
that and or for you to for future
generations of deal of energy students
to work on so please document any
projects you come across and I will be
getting you on Friday the sheet of how
to document so that you have a good
sense of what information you need to
gather but hopefully you're also getting
that today second is to really
understand the communities are working
in so you can do a good job of designing
with and for them what are their needs
what are their finances what is their
health their education culture
government both you know less critically
those some somewhat critically in terms
of understanding when grids arrived the
formal government also like the informal
community government that exists along
those lines formal informal leaders
lifestyles work etc and then doing the
charcoal trainings / great creative
capacity building as appropriate so I
want to talk a little bit about creative
capacity building which is a term that
Amy Smith coined for the way that she
hopes that aldi lab groups can work so I
want to talk about what she did at a
refugee camp in Uganda as an example so
this is a relief camp for Refugees new
ganda it looks kind of picturesque but
each one of those huts is about 10 or 12
feet in diameter and houses 20 people
generally and they've been living there
for 20 to 30 years so there's plenty of
people who have grown up in this refugee
camp it's their choice is to be there to
be completely unsafe if they're not in
the refugee camp either getting killed
or getting enlisted into the army and
because they're in a camp there's really
no natural resources or ability to do
work so there's a real culture of
dependency things are finally safe
enough that this group of
people is getting and it's about a
hundred thousand people group of people
is getting ready to get repatriated back
to their original homes but people have
basically lived there their whole lives
and so there's this culture of
dependency how are we going to adjust
back to home there used to a very
centralized life in camp and adjusting
back and especially the burden on the
women going back is very high because
all of a sudden they now have to be
figuring out how to cook all the food
get all the water get all the wood etc
and there's been very little capacity
building in this camp up to now so what
Amy did when she was invited there was
initially do a technology demonstration
with a sort of classic d-lab technology
which is corn shellers and if you're
curious about them they're on the back
shelf back there so you can check them
out but basically the corn sheller
people generally korn shell corn by hand
it's really labor-intensive and
relatively painful to do because the
corn is dry and it's really hard to get
off and so do you have identified this
injection molded corn sheller is
something that can work in a lot of
communities really well but it's really
hard to injection mold at the community
level it requires really high pressure
and plastic neither of which are
available and so do them develop two
ways of making that corn sheller either
by welding or by bending sheet metal
that are really easy to make basically
anywhere and allow people to shell their
own corn very quickly very affordably
and people really loved it so that
they're really excited and so this is
kofi who traveled with Amy and is
another deal of staff member they taught
them how to make their own corn shellers
and people are really pumped and so this
is both just a tech transfer sort of
like doing a charcoal demonstration I'm
teaching you how to make these corn
shellers and hopefully you can start
making them for yourselves and using
them awesome but also to start inspiring
conversation about well what else do you
need and how else could it be how could
those needs be addressed together and so
one of the projects that was discussed
was grinding so grinding their corn this
is a traditional grinding stone you can
imagine how hard it is to use this stone
to successfully grind dried corn how
labor-intensive it is
and people found it they also are
actually the not corn excuse me they
grind sesame and ground outs which are
peanuts in it and again it's very
labor-intensive so first so that was the
issue post was how do we grind our
sesame and peanuts more easily and so
first they looked at what the commercial
method is in that area as a commercial
grinder which requires diesel and is
totally unaffordable for this community
so they said all right that's not going
to work so let's design our own and so
in a day they found a meat grinder and
put together this really basic crappy
prototype and partly it was crappy
because they had a day and partly using
is crappy intentionally because they
built this with community partners Amy
and Kofi really took the lead but
working very closely with the local
builders as well as the local people and
so people got a really good sense of how
one could develop this project really
fast without the fancy MIT education
that Amy brings to the table but just
they got their head around oh this is
how I could do this and got really
excited and they also saw how relatively
crappy this was and how they need to be
improvements and so they started saying
things like when I build mine I'm going
to do this which is a really good
indicator that there now feeling
empowered to build their own rather than
when you come back and build me another
one it's going to look like this right
and that's the that's the goal is right
when I wield mind rather than when you
come back and build me mine so people
got really excited and just tried it out
and it was a great outcome so this sort
of experience helped Amy solidify her
thinking about creative capacity
building which is we're not there for
just for tech transfer we're not there
just to identify problems and then come
back to MIT and fix them but working
with people side by side through all
areas of the design process to help them
develop their own solutions to problems
and work together with them and the
nature of the dlab trip going in for a
week in spring break is we can't fully
achieve all of this but at least if we
have this in mind we can achieve as much
of it as possible some of the amazing
things that happen on this trip is that
the translator they were working with
told them that they were the first
foreigners that this camp had ever seen
who actually did work because most
people who come to do relief work come
with clipboards and do a lot of
interviews and ask a lot of questions
this is not to attack all relief work
great there's a lot of great early work
that goes on but there's also a lot of
clipboard question asking and there's a
need for that but actually having people
come and do work and work side by side
is pretty valuable so for an example
here's Kofi chopping wood for making
fires because that's what needed to be
done so he helped out doing it and
that's the kind of thing that you might
start to do when you're in your
community next week however you don't
see a picture of Amy chopping wood but
you do see a picture of Amy helping
sweep up after their demonstration and
why is that well it's totally culturally
inappropriate forum you to chop wood
this is will be inappropriate for Kofi
to help sweep up and so while it's great
to break down gender barriers at some
level you also need to be respectful and
so Amy will happily chop firewood when
given the opportunity but if it's
totally inappropriate she won't and vice
versa so it's a balancing act about
helping people but also being respectful
of what's appropriate so it can be very
easy in communities to let people just
help you people will be really kind of
gracious and serve you and it's really
important to make sure that your acting
is a community member working rather
than someone who's a visitor or guest
even though you are only being helped
the general rule of thumb is that Amy
likes to say is people are people so if
it's you would help someone out here
doing something you should do it there
and vice versa if you'd be really
uncomfortable helping X here then you
don't need to be force yourself to be
super uncomfortable there some of the
advantages of doing this sort of
participatory work are its efficient and
that's the sort of deceptive thing to
say it's efficient because it takes a
really long time and can be really
frustrating however if you're delivering
a product that no one actually needs or
is excited about then there's a real
loss of efficiency there by not working
with them in the first place and
similarly it can be effective to really
work with people and get some
it's really valuable it can help
transition people to a level of
self-reliance they didn't have
previously and help your projects and
the work become sustainable some of the
disadvantages are it's slow it takes a
long time it requires a lot of human and
material resources potentially there's a
lot of unpredictability as most teams
have already experienced and if you
haven't you will experience and you have
to be able to just roll with that
unpredictability rather than getting
super frustrated by it I mean you will
get super frustrated by it but not
letting that frustration be the dominant
experience and then finally ex managing
expectations both of not getting your
community partners thinking that you're
going to do something magical that isn't
actually within your power or vice versa
you yourself thinking you're going to be
doing something amazing that's actually
not reasonable to expect in the time and
reach with the resources you have so the
typical design process is you're trying
to go from a problem solution and you
generally go through generating ideas
evaluating them designing in more detail
actually building testing and evaluation
it's not actually this linear of course
but that's the general idea and so
traditionally you would involve
communities just at the end and that's
obviously not ideal for all the reasons
we've talked about and so then hopefully
you involve them in the beginning and
the idea of co-creation is that you're
involving your community throughout all
stages and so one thing to talk about
when you are there is all right I'm not
going to be here for the next few weeks
while I'm doing all these steps how can
I stay connected with you what's the
best way way to be in contact with you
it says that you can involve your
community partners as much as possible
there any questions about all that
yeah so all everyone so Lindsay is both
really useful as a go-between but she
also can't answer all the questions that
you are going to have because Lindsay is
one of the organizers of group of
Phoenix and so Lindsay maybe the person
you need to use to get the answers from
the lumen you're working with but you
can't just rely on Lindsay reasonably
but she may be the best way to get
information so speaking of information I
want to talk a little bit about what the
barriers are to getting information and
some of the methods so what makes
getting good information hard and what
would you do to get good information and
by information I mean learning you know
is this solar cooker design actually a
good idea how often do you cook with the
solar cooker etc etc yeah
language down
what else
whichever
ask the question of the time
ostracism yep
we
I observation well I think both actually
what else
cultural yeah
two
sometimes you go right into like some
people say one thing but some people
think another so happy
yeah absolutely
maybe like will want to like a bypass
small
like introducing ourselves and that was
established in person
yeah yeah you can get much better
information from people if you actually
spend the time to do the introductions
and thankfully for you guys you're not
in a community where it traditional to
spend like an hour doing the introduced
introductions and how's your family and
this and that in Nicaragua at least in
these areas people are used to doing
things a little more quickly but doing
the Steve Ray approach not his remote
but what he did of Guardian right in and
be like oh let me see your shoelaces is
probably not the best spending the time
to introduce yourself and get to know
people a little bit it's definitely
going to help okay so gender yep
you cannot what doesn't have very much
of like men
expense we talked to but I would say
it's not as Extreme as other places I
don't know it could be I didn't
encounter it as a big issue but it's
it's always a possibility so some of the
issues I have encountered myself are so
yes the language and sometimes you deal
with that with the translator whether
it's someone on your team or someone on
your in your community organization is
helping educational backgrounds are
different cultural backgrounds are
different people tell you what you want
to hear what they think you want to hear
as opposed to what you actually want to
hear and you may be easily talking to
the wrong person so to get into those a
little more so language obviously is
challenging and when you use a
translator there's often times where you
ask a question that you know takes you
two minutes to say and the translator
asks a one second question and then the
person responds by talking for three
minutes and the translator says yes and
that can be really frustrating and at
the same time you're completely beholden
to your translator so if you take them
outside and yell at them I mean I don't
think that's going to happen right but
if that you know if you took a really
pissed-off approach to this the effect
would be even worse response from your
translator educational backgrounds so
what I mean by that is that most of us
are pretty used to talking in watts in
jewels and inches whatever in units and
just with a math sense and if you
haven't had a math education you may
have a really intuitive understanding of
all those concepts but you don't
actually have the language the same
language so it's not a Spanish version
english barrier it's an educational
language barrier and so you are it's be
holdin on you when some you say well how
long is that expecting three inches and
someone you know answers like the you
know some other analogy figuring out how
to translate that rather than saying
well is that six inches or 8 inches
right because that's not going to give
you very useful information
I saw both yeah
but a lot of it is without standard
units to like a lot of people just
aren't used to units and units of
measure like what you're used to
cultural background of course and then
telling you what you want to hear it's
really common if you say so what do you
think of my design right for you'll be
like oh it's great yeah we totally use
that awesome love it yeah it's good
mm-hmm and unless you both asked your
question more carefully and keep probing
you'll never hear beyond that and it's
really easy when you're proud of
something to be like well they said do
they love it awesome and so working
through that is important and then also
talking to the wrong person so it can be
really easy to ask all your questions of
Lindsey for example is the community
organizer and she speaks English etc and
she'll give you some really good
insights but if you just talk to her you
won't get the right information or you
can interview someone about cooking
habits and then if you forget to ask how
often do you cook and find out actually
they aren't the cook but they'll answer
because you're asking these questions if
you don't ask the right questions you're
just never going to get that right an
information and there's classic examples
of that in terms of talking to the male
leaders in the community and never
talking to the women in the community I
think that'll be less of an issue for
most of you guys given who you're
working with but it's something to keep
in mind so I sort of got to this and you
got to it too so one some of the methods
to manage this are asking the same
person the same question in many
different ways multiple times as well as
asking different people the same
question multiple times anticipating
that you're going to get some variation
another thing you can do is ask some
questions that you kind of already know
the answer to if you do so that you get
an indicator of how reliable this person
is in terms of giving you useful
information because some people are much
more on the telling you what you want
where they think you want to hear sigh
than others and there's some probing
questions you may be able to develop
that can help you get around that
demonstrating an openness to criticism
and that generally does not mean saying
oh you won't offend me tell me whatever
you want but can mean something like you
know I've talked to some people who
criticized or you know have said they
don't like this idea because of this you
know is that something that you think
might be a problem
2yr why not and just repeatedly
attacking yourself so that that you
actually get some criticisms from them
because as great as you all are I'm sure
there's going to be some flaws and every
approach and so getting to those flaws
helps you get to a really great product
faster repeating answers back is sort of
a classic method for making sure that
there's understanding on both sides
encouraging questions very explicitly
saying you know what questions do you
have for me what can I tell you it's
pretty important verifying expertise so
sort of as I mentioned it the wrong
person if you talk to some about cooking
actually making sure that they cook
would be a good good thing to do and
then finally doing the translator
spending some time beforehand talking
about what your goals are what your
preferences are because translators have
choices in terms of did they give you
the detailed response or do they just
give you the yes and if you're on a time
crunch you may just want the yes but if
you have the time you probably want the
detailed answer with the subtleties even
if it's more painful to translate so one
of the challenges is when you're working
on engineering projects is getting to
the core problem and that sort of ties
in to the project specifications so
someone will say I need a new stove
instead of I need to not have such a
smoky environment in my kitchen and you
need to make sure you're asking the
questions to get to smoky environment
not new stove right and be really easy
to specify that brand new stove without
getting the right and question answered
which is the smoky environment so partly
it's making sure that you're not letting
them design for you which everyone does
it's really hard to describe what you
need in terms of specifications is you
probably just found out or sawn that to
double nine lecture I linked to when
trying to describe a lemon or a piece of
fruit as a project specification rather
than I need a lemon right that's a much
harder but that's when you act this is
actually the information you need to
make a good design so that you're not
going down the path of a design that may
not actually match the real need
because it's easier to think in products
than specifications so getting to the
core problem some ways you can do that
in addition to just being patient when
people talk about what they want in
terms of a product and then you
translating back in the specifications
is so tell me what would happen when you
use this new thing tell me a story about
what that would be like and have them
sort of walk you through what life is
like with this new option talk you know
when you're trying to find out more
about what those specifications are
rather than saying how big should it be
saying well how big is too big is 10
feet you know is this big too big is
this big too big and again i just said
10 feet and that's probably not what you
want to say you want to use your hands
to gesture or use up some other things
to compare because 10 feet even for us
is a little hard to imagine exactly how
big 10 feet is and for someone who
hasn't grown up using rulers and tape
measure etc it's harder and so I put big
and small in parentheses because it
could be like how hot how cold how
whatever all sorts of different things
challenge challenge the requests so like
if they say oh no it has to be you know
it can't be bigger than this say well
what would happen if it was this big why
would that be a bad thing so that you
really understand what they're getting
had and then get getting feedback on
your own ideas including ones that you
know are problematic so showing them a
design that you know has some issues and
getting feedback on it trying to get
them comfortable with criticizing so
that you can and then also listening to
the way they're criticizing what they're
catching maybe open up some information
for you and then finally as you're
engaged in these questions and
conversations taking time mentally to
review what you know and sort of do a
mental design process of writing down
the specifications and being like okay I
know these things what else do I know so
that you make sure to get to all the
questions you need to ask and it's kind
of hard and takes practice but you guys
will do great so now I'm going to save
that till Friday because we're running
out of time
so I just wanted to go over or maybe
I'll go back to it a five-time the
packing list and trip advice which is
all posted on stellar but in case you
haven't had a chance to read it I know
they're kind of long so some people are
earlier asking me do I need to buy a new
x probably not so there might be one or
two things you want to buy but generally
the goal of D lab is not to make
yourself broke going to travel to a
developing country um so very little
needs to be bought new pack lately which
is in direct contradiction to the
two-page packing list that I provided
you but basically that two-page packing
list is the list of all things that
someone at d-lab really likes ringing
and so some people really value certain
things other people bring value other
things you sort of have to know yourself
what are the objects that are going to
be important for you to have and what
are the ones that you can skip so
they're just a couple that i have on
that packing list that are in blue I
didn't even put underwear and blue right
just the ones like a flashlight that if
you don't have it's going to be really
hard for you to function so things like
that you have to have everything else a
sort of your call so if you don't have
TVs you don't have hiking boots you
don't have whatever don't worry about it
don't go out and buy yourself a 200 pair
of hiking boots that you'll never wear
again just for this trip that's not
necessary so pack lightly with that
being said it can be as cold as like 50
degrees at night so you might want a
light fleece or something like that and
then in the middle of the day it's a
wicked hot and humid relatively
conservative dress again for a lot of
these things I'm asking you to be more
conservative than you may see most
people being not most but many people in
Nicaragua being because again we're
representing MIT and D lab and the audio
de and so we want to be respectful to
the people who are on the conservative
side in terms of dress etc toiletries so
if you have any medications that you
need to take you should take twice as
many as you need and keep them in two
separate places so that if the bag gets
stolen or lost you have your meds you
definitely want to bring toilet paper or
tissues or something like that you can
use for toilet paper because not all
places will have it you won't be offered
a towel so if you want to have it
howl for showering which will be bucket
showers so taking a scoop of water from
a bucket and pouring it on your head you
should bring one but I would bring a
small one because they're pretty bulky
you definitely want bug repellent and
sunscreen the Sun is much stronger and
you will sunburn if you don't wear
sunscreen if you're fair-skinned
flashlight again is key having a
photocopy of your passport bringing a
notebook like I mentioned and then
nothing of value so you shouldn't be
wearing your brass rats you could skip
earrings or we're really small subtle
ones cameras like a small junkie
point-and-shoot is fine but a dlsr is
not ideal again you'll see some people
in Nicaragua with the LS ours but
they're making the choice for themselves
about having that and therefore bringing
the potential crime associated with
having a fancy device there and it's not
fair for you to make that call for your
entire team on that camera yeah
theft so do you have a point do you have
a waterproof shockproof dlsr it's like
the big yeah yeah so so a point shoot
totally fine yeah yeah so this is I'm
saying so like a camera that's this size
is fine a camera that's that size not
fine it's what i was saying ones that
have like the switch out of the lenses
is a deal as are you know fancy nice
camera that's what i'm asking you not to
take point and shoot you should totally
take and then that laptops your team
probably shouldn't bring any laptops if
you need to you should bring one but
definitely not more than that yeah yes
so i recommend bringing as much memory
and battery charging capability as you
can both because you'll have limited
access to electricity for battery
charging and then you may be taking a
lot of pictures and you may not have a
laptop and be able to download them
until you get home i'm not sure why
that's
yeah so the thing that's complicated is
so every trip leader will have a cell
phone with them so for emergencies
there's a way to call the states or way
to call within your country or whatever
you need I can't see why you'd need a
cell phone like it might be nice to have
during your layover zor whatever so you
might want to bring it for that reason
but if it's anything at all nice and i'm
concluding like my junkie phone as nice
but anything that looks fancier than
like flip phones that people had like 10
years ago should never be visible in
nicaragua so if you're going to bring it
pack it in the bottom of your bag you
know as soon as you get to Miami and
leave it there rather than taking it out
so and again like you'll see a few
people with iphones but in nicaragua but
they're taking a risk and you shouldn't
have yours out and about while you're
there but the one thing is that most of
you are leaving super super early on
sunday so you do want to have your cell
phone out that morning in that middle of
the night just to make sure you're awake
I don't know a 3am like I feeling which
you probably won't even sleep right like
I know I don't go to sleep if I have to
leave a three but yeah we want to make
sure you get there so one other thing
you want to bring is gifts for your
community partners and so some criteria
for what makes a good gift is one that
is not extravagantly over-the-top
expensive because it can sort of set up
a the disparity between wealth can be
more significant and make people feel
uncomfortable also you may well be on a
budget and I don't want you to go broke
buying gifts for your family other
things are will they actually use it
will this just become some piece of
trash that adds trash to the community
in places where they're relatively
pristine and we or not but we don't want
to be adding to the trash load etc so d
lab has a few things that we buy that
are branded is d lab objects that you
can buy from d labs if gifts are not
something that d-lab pays for it
something that you
pay for as a team or an individual
because they're from you and so it's up
to you to decide how much but I think
something is appropriate so sports
bottles or five dollars these hats maybe
six or eight dollars hats I think are
pretty good gift because people can wear
them and they like them and a lot of
people wear baseball caps but don't
bring them Red Sox caps because most of
them like Yankees and those are the only
two teams that aren't basically known
from what I saw we also have these
little flashlights oh I think the
battery is blocked so I can't turn it on
but yeah the challenge of these
flashlights as it means the battery has
to be replaced and things like that so
it's a mixed bag how valuable it is but
they're they're fun these little
drawstring bags which people like I
often bring chocolate to share with my
family like I'll bring a couple hats to
bring for like someone like Lindsey or
someone who's helping you a lot and then
for the family just bring chocolate that
you can share with them trader joe says
pretty good pretty cheap chocolate that
travels pretty well some chocolate melts
really easily and that's not ideal for
given how hot it is let some of the
nicer chocolate comes in like three
packs for like two bucks and just
sharing that with your family I mean
something you can share with all the
members and it's nice and it's from your
home country chocolate and Nicaragua in
my opinion isn't far inferior to
chocolate States and a lot of people i
know agree and so it's something like
that is also appropriate so are there
any questions on gifts so i'm trying to
leave a little time at the end of this
class so that your team can make a list
of all the things you need from d-lab
and these gift things are among them in
terms of money that you might need so
you should bring your charlie card
because you'll probably be coming back
on the tee if not going there there's an
entry visa cost to get into Nicaragua of
ten dollars and if you just have a
ten-dollar bill on you it's nice to not
have to deal with the customs agent
making change if you're bringing cash so
you may want some cash for food that's
not already prepaid which you guys will
reimburse
or after the trip or for gifts for
yourself to bring home two for yourself
or family members at the airport if not
while you're traveling there'll be
opportunities to do a little shopping so
you shouldn't bring anything bigger than
a twenty-dollar bill and smaller bills
are nicer generally because it's hard
for people to make change but the bill
should be in decent condition if they're
really ratty people won't take them and
then if you expect to be needing to use
your bank or credit card or debit card
for either for general just getting
money out of an ATM or for an emergency
you should call them to warn them that
you're traveling so that if you do need
it you can because usually they'll block
any charges unless you told them ahead
of time some tips so you should assume
that drinking water is unsafe which
means that any vegetables or fruits that
aren't cooked are also unsafe because
they were probably washed in that unsafe
drinking water so each team team trip
leader will have a water filter that you
guys can use to filter your own water
which means you really do want to bring
a water bottle so that you can clean
have clean water in that water bottle
but this is definitely something to be
cautious on so you stay healthy for the
trip because it's such a short trip that
if you get sick for a few days that's
half your trip nothing nothing expensive
at least in sight or brought so you know
like a brass rat or nice jewelry or
watch or whatever leave here if you need
to bring that cell phone so you have it
while you're in the States while you're
traveling just keep it hidden in your
bag so that it's not brought attention
to being brought attention to at all you
should always be traveling in groups
ideally but especially at night there's
going to be some cases where that'll be
tricky but do your best to be as safe as
possible as i mentioned flexibility and
patience are really great assets to have
so just sort of go in not expecting to
be as efficient or effective as you next
necessarily hoped and sort of expect
that things are going to change at the
last minute and that will help make the
trip more fun rather than frustrating
and then managing expectations or the
community partners
it's really easy for Cutie partners to
be like when are you coming back and
you're so pumped you're having such a
great time you're like I'll be back this
summer like not thinking about well
actually I have that internship at
whoever and I'm not going to be back
this summer may never be back and so you
don't want to make any promises that you
can't keep that's really important
because that can ruin our relationship
with other community partners so just a
reminder a few of you still owe me at
least some of these things and so please
get them to me today or tell me why you
can't and what you're going to do if you
haven't already and so for the remainder
of the class i need to do micro
interviews with everyone who's traveling
it's just a dlab thing that we do we
just talk one-on-one really briefly you
may want to revise your plan a little
bit based on feedback from the
presentations you probably want to talk
in your group about how much check
luggage you're having versus carry on
who's carrying what for any bulky items
you have things that you might need from
d-lab I need you to tell me by the end
of class today so you might need tools
you might need cameras we have some that
we can lend mosquito nets hammocks other
it'd be nice of at least a few people
have cameras so that you can get
different angles of shots when you're
all taking pictures together and also if
one dies you're not unable to take
pictures because pictures are really
important for the projects and then
anything else you might need so are
there any questions about all that okay
cool
you
you